but this top eight is absolutely bananas
the first batch we're gonna have coming
your way when we eventually get to it's
gonna be Korea me versus Japan no B
that's the winner side of our top eight
no B has been playing ridiculous he came
in Group D played and he was like you
know what Tekken is a Japanese game this
is from Japan from Japan keep smoking
people look what happened where did that
nobody come from it's look it's a whole
new ball game
first off I also want to say shoutouts
to Pakistan man they have definitely
breathed a lot more I do a lot of like
shoutouts to arson ash shoutouts to but
y'all y'all already you guys are why
honey oh wise honey old match the John
one of my favorites all year bro
if I had a trophy to give you would
definitely cancel Player of the Year
no Mississippi man I know there's a lot
of haters on the internet man but
Pakistan you guys really pull through
this year you guys made Tekken World
Tour something else this year for sure
it's definitely been quite the
experience right and now we have another
brand new high character in the game of
ticket now he saves name thief I don't
know don't tell me to do that I know
what you're trying to do rip I'm trying
to get me in trouble just a lot of stuff
got y'all about that I'm definitely a
puppet but before we go any further I
believe we have our two players on the
stage where we go it is going to be none
other than rocks dragons knee versus
team your box adobe these guys gonna be
playing on the winners side of top mate
here this one's gonna be crazy nobody
has been playing out of his mind I don't
remember the last time I saw no he's
played this well and me of course you
know finally getting run back against
arson as beating him in tournament
earlier preventing him from getting into
this group but here we go this will be
our first matchup in the top eight of
the Tekken World Tour Finals 2019 are
you guys ready to put us out there
no no no no are you guys ready for this
out there
that felt like they here guys our first
match is about to commence I hope you're
ready for some of the best ticket excuse
me some good ass-kicking let's go
game on knee going with the Steve Fox
nobody with the dragon off we've seen a
multiple time switch up characters that
he's going to play how he's going to
play and he's been doing a lot of
research even went to Pakistan tickets
an extra phone to his gameplay but
nobody doesn't care about any of it he
says this is a Japanese go oh my gosh
that's a quick turnaround first round of
me here too
I expect us to go back and forth the
whole way through this and members top
in so many killers in it look it's so
scary man I mean I feel like the bracket
the way that it was set up for all these
players to be made in to get into top
eight says everything that it needs to
say you had to beat the best in the
world to be here easy the rest of
assault nice up for for this rounded
looking a lot better for Doby answers
back instant and man the Japanese crowd
is in full support of know me of course
this man the crowd so far today has a
bit ridiculous it's over he's written a
lot of look Russian assault gonna
connect this time each I know absolute
ones really close to their wall right
now my heart a story I'm sweating
profusely right now I am NOT a sweaty
guy but damn ok teammates out for smash
get off of me bro he's trying to throw
multiple times hasn't gotten it to work
just yet get off me rage mode now avail
for me
wild man when sprayed the rage drive
sonic drive blocked oh wow wanted that
he would have broke their throw never
goes up two rounds to one here winner
semis that means this is still two out
of three ladies and gentlemen just like
normal
Oh better good boy good night beatdown
punch with a 4-4-2 on the follow-up
I like the slow approach right now me
with the life lead another up for for
whole conversion hereby note we had the
wall on top of him it's offered at
converters and on their carrying tons of
damage counter it down to that's I put
it down to some more I mean both these
guys playing on point up beautiful with
punching beautiful spacing and look at
the down she's counter hitting no trying
to close the foot and reg boat indeed
not gonna let it happen final round game
one and coming tied up on the rounds in
the first game they're not gonna let
this go easy you know he has been doing
all the proper traveling the training to
try to get to this but he wants to get
that twt and know he is a countryman at
this point he's playing for the country
and himself that be called careful he's
getting close to that breakable balcony
get off with me bro
taking their time is so close though and
they're gonna really poke the poke right
now singles down to single low kicks
dancer back with the down to you can
make the slope countdown for to just go
for the easy stuff yeah look any of you
want to insert a car but we simply could
end it around
yeah Devils but you know you doesn't
play all these characters like to their
optimal potential last picks up no
dispensaries drive doesn't get the
balcony 17 seconds
nobody with a flow combo to be huge
balcony breaks here and it's gonna be
highly skilled but he's gonna get the
wall again 10 seconds on the clock do I
find all this tonic drive on his wake up
let me get the first game
[Applause]
man looking really good in his first
game already but we've seen no pee-wee I
feel like he's the freshest out of the
bunch right I'm feeling he just came
from his long stint this crazy
goofy play and he's still looking sharp
but this first game is gonna go to me
and let's not forget you know you look
at the history of this tech world tour
he has never won but twt oh that is
definitely true so you know he wants
this extra pair like I mean yeah sure he
got his run back against Arsenal right
but he still has a wanted tea that we
tea last you're very close ended up a
third place and he was look I feel like
he was barely able to make it into this
top eight I mean I feel like that Arthur
Ashe match took a lot out of a pair he
is mm-hmm and they're gonna run it back
to same characters Steve Fox versus
dragon off all right let's see what he's
gonna do to change up this pace change
the results of what could potentially
happen great offense so far defense even
better
nobody is just kind of you know space
trying to push me trying to get a
reaction out of nothing oh yeah and in
that crazy group nobody was in to almost
everyone if we got the honey when you
look at the first game there Sony
getting the first game here that's huge
now if couches are filing me with the
block and one of them drop the blue
stuff gets another round on the floor
for me he's been on point The Rose
raised rice his timing right he know the
timing window buddy wants to try to
avoid it he's been catching on will pull
pull pull that back one look at the
sleep standing up gonna hit the wall hit
believe in old the okey-doke step on his
feet first no Jackson do it again no get
off me oh poor poor man he just looks
like he's in control right now pretty
good life lead wait a minute finally
gets up for for the wall misses up the
cobble there's a to break ya know be
staying close here that's where Steve
wants you to be there that's oh we want
to hit you and we're fine with that back
one
look at the dance real quick all the
hollering all the down to meet with
steel even when he caught that low
period oh gosh and just like that it's
gonna be set point for me to advance to
the winner's final of this tournament
but no ducks walked into from novi
handed to him back here this should end
up at the wall
definitely season three say yeah big
damage almost 50% gone instantly no P is
in trouble though two out of three is
the name of the game right now they're
trying to get two winners finals and
right after that grand finals but I
gotta get hit fast this first the Lopo
adding up here from me trying to close
out three rounds for the second game
don't walk that that time know me with
rage now well to get off 30 seconds left
on the clock doping down to Oh Russian
assault no beat it's still alive an
accidental jump on me but it was costly
ducking out of their jabs gets the wild
man Kabul walked in and one two from me
Oh retching assault again get off the
low family working out perfect he is
looking in top form so far definitely
wants to get the W but no B look at him
he's not afraid he's going in on his ki
[ __ ] he's way behind this round up I
like that up for right there trying to
see if me he's gonna duck and it's been
pretty successful but not anymore now
nobody's in trouble this is set point
for D right now just held back and
walked out of range because of the delay
no raise now he's got the makings come
back the old fashioned way 20 seconds on
the clock
get off for me bro and advance himself
to the winners final guaranteed myself a
top 10 finish back to back
look you already said like and you made
a very very good point
since we've you know evolved regular
ticket tournaments to the king of Iron
Fist tournament to the Tekken World Tour
if he has not claimed any of those
victories yet and everybody knows he is
one of the best to ever do it possibly
the best taken player ever so imagine
what this means to him to possibly get
a ticket wall to a title when it's when
it's especially when it's the toughest
this is definitely a special tournament
right I mean in the past of course we
had COO Don's yet he had rank Chu last
year another contender in this top eight
who has not won a title yet is a lot of
these players actor but JDC are very
notable you know also a top three
finishers that did not win no that's
definitely true but I feel like that's
what's happening now there's so many
people like getting into the world of
Tekken trying to claim that spot and
it's not gonna be easy there's so many
players you'd have to get through
speaking up there's two of them on the
screen right now double chicken in this